hey guys it's amy from tasty uk and
today i'm going to be trying the recipes
of three celebrities to decide who makes
the best avocado toast in this morning's
lineup we have cosmetic queen kylie
jenner the real queen of america meghan
markle and since we're talking royalty
the potty mouth prints himself gordon
ramsay so who's gonna take the crown
let's find out so we're gonna kick off
with kylie jenner's recipe this one is
relatively simple and i am an avocado
toast purist so you just slice your two
avocados in half i'm just gonna score
across the flesh to make it easier to
come out so many people went to hospital
with avocado hand injuries from removing
the stone like that so to safely remove
the avocado stone you place a tea towel
in your hand pop the avocado in there
and confidently
voila kylie wants to show us that she is
a master of everything and we've seen a
lot of her cooking on her socials she's
done frosted flakes french toast which i
actually made and her french toast was
banging i have high expectations for
this so i'm gonna scoop out the avocado
flesh and give it a mash in this bowl so
you know your avo is ripe when you pick
off the stem and beneath that you see
green avocado toast was a huge thing a
few years ago
every cafe in east london worth its salt
has avo toast on the menu so this is
looking really nice and smooth now so
we're ready to plate a great tip to stop
your avocado from browning if you're not
quite ready to plate just put a bit of
cling wrap on the surface of the avocado
that way it cannot oxidize and go brown
so i'm going to go ahead and spoon this
avocado onto this lovely piece of toast
i'm going to do a nice thick layer a
nice
drizzle of agave a sprinkle of chili and
a finished bit of salt and that is it
wow so this looks glistening and
gorgeous look at that ratio of abbott
bread that is perfect
i like it it's very interesting to put
something sweet on an avocado toast
which isn't typically something i would
go for but i think the salt and the
chili is a really good addition i don't
think this is an everyday thing if
you're looking for a dessert avocado
toast this is the way to go
but like i said i'm a purist on a scale
of one to five five being the best i'm
giving kylie jenner's avocado toast a
2.5 i don't hate it that's a wrap on
kylie's recipe let's see how megan
measures up i'm really excited about
this one because i think adding a salty
cheesy feta like element is gonna really
elevate this dish we're gonna slice our
avo in half this recipe calls for one
avocado to two slices of toast so it's a
little bit stingy but maybe it's going
to be good again with the avocado trick
hey
we're going to score this avid just to
make sure it's easier to get out the
skin i heard that megan is a keen cook
and it's actually how she snagged a
prince the story goes that prince harry
proposed to her the day that she had
cooked a roast chicken i have not myself
tried or seen any of megan's recipes but
i can tell she's got a taste for spice
she's going around adding spice to the
royal family's lives that's for sure so
we're just going to scoop these avo's
out we're going to mash this oven until
it's nice and smooth so i've half mashed
this and now i'm going to add a
tablespoon of batter and then give it a
good mix i'm using vegan better but you
can really use any that you like i have
high expectations for this one salty
spicy creamy what's not to love i don't
think this looks the most visually
appealing but i think the flavor is
gonna pack a punch so now we're gonna
add some lemon juice lemon juice makes
everything better i got it mostly in the
bowl now i've added the lemon juice this
is ready to plate so for megan's recipe
we're using multi-grain bread and this
is a bit of me i love this kind of bread
pop this avocado on the spread the bread
to guac ratio is not indulgent enough
for me it's got to be 50 50. this is
flat adding a little bit more height and
texture with extra crumbles of feta add
some chili flakes a bit of salt you
can't have avo toast that is unseasoned
and a few pepitas for crunch and there
we go meghan markle's avocado toast i'm
trying to find an area where there's
some chunkiness to this and i know you
guys are going to be mad but i'm going
to take a bite out of the middle like
this
it was a toast sensation you know i was
mad about the ratios but it actually
works and i think that's because of the
feta you first get the creamy avocado
layer and then you get these sort of
punches of salty cheese which is just
delicious and then on top of all of that
you have the sprinkle of chili flakes
which just makes this perfect i got that
all in one bite well done megan i'm
gonna give this avocado toast a four out
of five i know i'm just as surprised as
you this does really work so well done
so now the one that i am the most
excited about it is chef ramsay's avo
toast this next one is the most chefy of
them all there are more steps in it you
actually have to do some cooking rather
than just assembling let's see if it's
worth it i'm going to add some oil to
the pan and saute my chorizo i'm using
vegan chorizo you can use any you like
i'm going to cook this until the edges
are nice and crisp and then we'll move
on to adding the onion i think part of
the appeal of avocado toast is how quick
and simple it is to make but you know
what i like the effort that he's gone to
he's put the gordon ramsay spin on it
and i'm into that oh so now the edges
are looking nice and crispy i'm gonna
add the onion and give that a little
saute
[Music]
i haven't personally tried gordon's
vegan recipe i feel like he said
something mean about vegans and since
then we've not been friends so now the
onion is nice and sauteed we're going to
add the garlic just cook it until we can
smell it because there's nothing more
unforgivable than burnt garlic
unforgivable that smells so good i'm
gonna make a gap in the pan to add my
tomatoes
tomatoes
we have one cup so i'm going to add them
cut side down to the center of the pan
to give them a nice sear this is the
most elaborate avocado toast i've ever
seen i could only make this recipe after
my first cup of coffee but look it looks
like some kind of child's art it's like
a preschool painting the tomatoes are
looking nice and sweaty we're just gonna
wait until they brown on the bottom and
then we'll deglaze the pan everyone
loves gordon ramsay in england is that
true i mean i can't speak for the whole
of england but gordon ramsay's a pretty
liked guy i love gordon ramsay's duets
gordon if you're watching come at me
with your duets on tiktok check out my
lasagna pie the tomatoes are looking
nice and charred so i'm gonna deglaze
the pan with some vegetable stock the
recipe calls for chicken stock but i'm
using veggie today it smells super
fragrant paprikay garlicky
meaty
smells meaty it's looking very
sophisticated we've grown up we've
levelled up so this is nice and reduced
and it smells gorgeous and juicy we're
going to add a splash of sherry vinegar
give it a good season with salt and mix
it up a sprinkle of parsley so this was
quite a lot of work but it's looking
interesting i'm curious to see how this
is all going to come together so we've
got new components there's a lot going
on here so we're going to take it step
by step don't worry i got you first of
all top tip we're going to slice our
piece of garlic
and rub the garlic on a freshly toasted
piece of bread just to add oomph to the
flavor so we're using country bread for
this recipe a personal favorite of mine
as of today when i learned what it was
okay so now it's finally avocado time so
for this recipe i'm going to slice the
avocado thinly and fan it out if you
want to find out how to make an avocado
rose i have a tutorial on my instagram
at amy tasty check it out i'm just going
to rub a bit of olive oil over the top
of the avo just to make it nice and
smooth and as good looking as it can be
and here we go with the slicing so half
an avocado per piece of bread and just
fan that out like so we're going to
season it with a bit of salt and a
squeeze of lemon next the pista
resistance is the chorizo mixture so i'm
just going to spoon this over each piece
giving it a nice generous layer mmm i
love the tomatoes all smushed up
pleasantly surprised by the aesthetics
of this dressing these leaves with a bit
of olive oil a touch of sherry vinegar
and just a sprinkle of salt you know i
don't think i've ever actually eaten avo
toasted lettuce so this is quite
uncommon i think this is kind of getting
far removed from the essence that is
avocado toast there's a lot going on
here but what's most important is how it
tastes so let's add these leaves on top
just for a bit of garnish a bit of extra
flavor bit of extra crunch the final
touches we have a sprinkle of parsley
finally
we have the manchego i'm using vegan
cheese you can use whatever cheese you
like this seems like an unnecessary step
you've gone too far gordon but we'll see
i mean he is a culinary genius so the
ratios are wild here this is different
from other recipes because rather than a
guacamole it's a sliced avocado which i
like but then you've gone and covered up
those gorgeous slices with all of these
other elements the topping to bread
ratio i'm a fan of because i like a lot
going on on the bread this is like
lifting weights
i'm gonna get some guns so let's give it
a go
[Music]
yes gordon that is good each individual
layer comes through i would make this
again but i wouldn't call this avocado
toast this is chorizo's album avocado is
just featuring on it i feel like the
avocado kind of gets lost i think maybe
the manchego was supposed to give it a
bit of a salty edge but you really get
that just from the chorizo but this is a
sunday morning breakfast when you've got
a bit more time to put a bit more energy
and love into it so it's going to come
as no surprise to anybody that the chef
is gonna make the best avo toast i'm
gonna give this a 4.5 out of five so
congrats gordon you won i'd suggest you
make gordon's recipe if you're feeling
fancy and you've got a bit more time on
a sunday but i'd go for megan's if i was
just making an everyday avocado toast
because it's got that little extra
something special without too much
effort and if you're looking for
something sweet sure try kylie's so
that's it from me today if you have any
other celeb showdown ideas let us know
in the comments thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you